une question qui m'a fait craquer ariane
comment marche une allumette une
allumette classique ariane ne peut pas
s'enflammer samson grattoir le grattoir
c'est cette partie un peu rugueuse sur
le côté de la boîte d'allumettes lorsqu
on frotte l'allumette sur le grattoir
cela provoque un échauffement local
phénomène que l'on connaît tous il
suffit de frotter vigoureusement nos
mains l'une contre l'autre pour
ressentir de la chaleur et bien cette
chaleur compte pro vote par friction
avec le grattoir fait monter la
température au niveau de la tête rouge
de l'allumette suffisamment pour que les
produits qui la composent du phosphore
et du chlorate de potassium
essentiellement réagissent avec l'air et
s'enflamme une flamme jaillit en
quelques dixièmes de seconde le bois de
l'allumette est en plus enduit de
paraffine cette substance grasse qu'on
trouve dans les bougies cela aide la
flamme à descendre le long de
l'allumette plutôt malin car sans ça la
flamme de notre allumettes nos frais
sont d'autres pas long feu